for some analysis on all this we're
joined now by our chief election and
campaign correspondent robert costa one
of the most knowledgeable reporters on
capitol hill uh bob good morning to you
uh the committee seemed to be at payne's
yesterday to make the point that the
president had access to good information
but chose to go with bad when talking
about the election how does that fit
into their overall effort here
good morning tony great to be with you
all to understand any story you need to
understand how it began and what we
heard in the testimony yesterday was the
beginning of the january 6th story and
what the committee did is trace it back
to a decision then president trump made
a decision to ignore his campaign
officials like former campaign manager
bill stephen ignore his own attorney
general and instead embrace the
conspiracy theories of rudy giuliani
sydney powell and other outside lawyers
and it was that decision the testimony
showed that put into effect this series
of events that ultimately led to an
attack on the capitol
bob the committee also made the point
that these lies were not just playing
with people's emotions or feelings but
also their wallets their pocketbooks
hundreds of millions of dollars went
into campaign coffers how was that money
spent and why was that a link made
that famous line from the watergate film
all the president's men follow the money
the deep throat mantra that's the same
mantra here when it comes to january 6.
this wasn't just about presidential
decisions it was about the money pouring
into an effort to back up a lie about a
presidential election and millions did
pour in for many grassroots supporters
of then president trump and some of them
are perhaps waking up today wondering
was that money effectively and properly
used
yeah and they're looking at the
headlines saying an economy may be
cratering and that money's not coming
back bob thank you very much thank you